if you as a person want to be able to do something
other than sitting on the sidelines while history
makes the decisions for you then you have to take
a side you have to pick the one that you think is
the best and throw yourself into repairing and
making that as best as it can be the alternative
they're facing is to just let the woke neo-marxas
swim not just to win at the level of government
but also to win in your personal life and what
I'm saying is that there there has to be an
alternative and think about it for a second that
alternative is not going to be liberalism it's not
going to be liberalism because liberalism is
what brought woke Neo Mark to them it's every
single institution that the wolf Neil marxists
are running now was a liberal institution 15
years ago so if liberalism had the antibodies
if it was enough to say let's just be free if
that was strong enough to be able to defeat open
near Marxism we wouldn't be where we are today
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantine
kitten and this is a show for you if you
want honest conversations with Fascinating People
our brilliant And Timely guest today is the author
of a new book conservatism a rediscovery
Europe has only welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me it's a pleasure uh we
cannot wait uh to speak with you we've got some
very interesting things to discuss before we do
though other than being the author of this book
tell everybody who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to us okay
the very the very short version if you want the
long version read the book the short version
is um I I live in Jerusalem married to Yael
we have nine children and at this point three
three grandchildren thank God more on the way
um I uh grew up in the United States as you
can hear I've met my wife in in college we've
founded a uh a a Reagan Thatcher publication
in college called the Princeton Tory and uh
since then I've been uh in involved in uh in Jew
Jewish and Israeli ideas I have a doctorate in
political Theory I I've published some books
on uh on on the Bible and its relevance to to
us today and uh most recently after the 2016
after 2016 the the the the brexit Trump year
um I gathered with some friends and colleagues and
we founded an international organization called
the the Edmund Burke Foundation which operates
uh in in in various Democratic uh countries the
Edmund Burke Foundation is uh runs the national
conservatism conferences uh which uh which have
been taking place for several years annually in
the United States and in Europe and there's going
to be a not con UK uh this this coming spring
well jorm it's uh great to have you on the show
because one of the things you talk about in the
book and uh you're not the only one talking about
it because I think quite a lot of smart people
are starting to realize uh what I'm about to say
I heard Peter Thiel talking at an At Con event uh
in the US uh and everybody you know me my friends
Francis we're all starting to understand that you
know we all know what we're against we're against
the idiocy of wokeness a lot of us uh Francis and
I particular also against some of the idiocy of
the anti-wokness that's starting to filter through
there are things that we all oppose but the
question I think for a lot of people is well what
are we for exactly what do we believe because you
know the caricature version of sort of owning the
libs uh gets old very quickly it's uninspiring it
doesn't offer anything it's not something that a
young person in particular can look at and go this
is what this is what I want to be the view of life
that I have this is how I'm going to go through
life these are the things I'm going to build
it's negative it's deconstructive rather than
being constructive there's no optimism there's no
creativity there's no building of anything so what
is it that conservatism of the way of the vision
that you describe has to offer to those people who
are perhaps looking for some kind of Middle Ground
between those two extremes well let let's be let's
begin with with liberalism because I I think the
most important thing to understand is that the
2020 was a was a watershed year uh in in Britain
in America and uh across many other democratic
nations it was the year that liberal ideas which
had been dominant you can say hegemonic at least
since the second world war 2020 was the year that
that uh hegemony dominance of liberalism broke
and the way that you can you can tell that is that
the the traditional liberal perspective let me let
me just Define it for a second the traditional
liberal perspective which says in in order to
understand to know what you need to know about
politics and about life what what liberals will
say what you need to know is that individuals are
by Nature free and equal that we take on moral and
political obligations on the basis of consent and
that the purpose of government is is to defend our
rights that had been for 50 60 70 years uh the the
basis for public life and most of the political
most of the major political parties in in the
west embraced one version or another of that
liberalism now conservatism is a is a different
is a different Beast conservatism is conservatives
begin from the question of I'm I'm born into a
family a a nation a religious tradition I'm I'm
born into various things that I did not create
I didn't construct them I might want to improve
them to add to them to build them up I might want
to reform them I might want to restore them but
the conservative asks about the inheritance that
we've received and fundamentally wants to know
what do we need to do in order to uh so that uh
so that our nation our our religion our political
inheritance can propagate across Generations
so as as you'll see in my book if you if you
if you take a look at it the difference between
this difference between someone who wants to
um to uh create a space in which we can all uh
pursue our own thing that's that's the liberal and
conservative is that the conservative says look
we've inherited many things and many of those
things are good and we need to figure out how to
build them up it conservatism is fundamentally a
creative project and those two groups anti-marxist
liberals anti-marxist conservatives we do have to
fight to fight side by side against the common
uh woke uh opposite uh the the the woke cultural
revolution which is on the verge of uh of of
winning but liberalism and conservatism are
two different things and and we will will each in
the end have to decide which side of that argument
we're on as well well we gotta we gotta win the
fight in terms of wokeness first but I suppose
the reason I bring up a positive vision of the
future which I think is sorely lacking or with
everyone who opposes wokeness at the moment uh is
that the question for me is why would I join your
fight from an Outsiders but I know why I'm
against working this because it mimics many
of the terrible things that I saw happen in my own
and my family's history and Francis likewise but
if I'm just a normal person in in the UK or in
America and I'm not too bothered about you know
all the stuff that I see on social media maybe I'm
not on social media why should I be either one of
these liberals or one of these conservatives and
oppose it so harshly if you don't have a slogan
for me you know join our fight and you get this
this and this or you get to keep this and this and
this but that's how people think right why should
I be on your side your own well conservatives
believe and I think this is true and I think that
more and more people will see this conservatives
believe that in order to be a healthy happy human
being uh you you actually have to be part of uh of
an inheritance uh which is then being handed down
again I I want to emphasize that that doesn't mean
you have to believe everything that is inherited
but conservatives think that you human nature is
such that if you raise children uh and you tell
them look do whatever you want do whatever feels
good use your own reason exercise your own
thinking and come to your own conclusions and
you don't give them anything else a great great
many people maybe the majority uh end up stuck and
unable to make the decisions among you know what
what exactly is it that I'm I'm I'm supposed to
do and what is it I'm supposed to believe so we we
have to start somewhere and I I suggest that the
question you know as I posed it that we begin with
what is it that you've inherited that you yourself
actually uh would like to see handed down to your
children to your grandchildren uh or or let's say
into the future maybe you don't have children
yet so that that that's that's a question so
traditional traditional World Views a Christian
worldview a Jewish world view a a nationalist
worldview a conservative world view all of
these World Views what they do is they uh they
they place you within a uh with a within a kind
of a hierarchy where the past hands down things
uh your your ancestors hand down things your
parents your your community hands down things
and you have a responsibility to uh to to fight
for those things you say why should you fight well
if if if you think that there are some things
that are better than other things then then
you should fight I mean it it doesn't feel good
to not fight if you're you're watching terrible
things happening and I think that's where we are
I think we are watching terrible things happening
like what do you mean by terrible things joram
well look I I'm going I'm going to describe this
from uh from my own perspective and I know that
you know many of your listeners you can get on
or get off you know what as as you see fit the
the uh the the world that uh Brits and Americans
and others fought for in the Second World War uh
was was a world in which uh there there was a a
framework of ideas those ideas um let's name some
of them uh God and scripture nation and family
um uh man and woman honor the sacred uh the the
the uh the Beautiful the free all of these ideas
are ideas that if if you take a look at what
have what has wokism been been doing since
since it's uh since its initial victory in
2020 what it's doing is overthrowing all of
these inherited Concepts okay so so uh as a a
Christian friend just told me a few weeks ago
he said look and here in Colorado he he helps
run a university there he said here in Colorado
um we used to have this wonderful liberal
idea that uh that each should be free to uh
to choose his own religion or lack of religion
in his own path and now we've moved from that
being the default position in society to the
default being that if uh if you don't honor
in this particular case the the the issue was
gay marriage but you don't have to agree about
that it can be other things if you don't honor
gay marriage we will force you publicly uh to to
to honor it there's no such thing anymore as as a
as a personal View and a PRI a private view now if
you're the kind of person who thinks um that uh
that the old liberalism uh where uh where we we
inculcated and attempted to hand on uh religious
Liberties if you think that that's not worth worth
fighting for so uh you know what what can I what
can I tell you if you don't if you don't think
that marriage is something that is worth fighting
for or that having children in the future or that
Britain continuing to exist is something worth
fighting for so I I understand you I feel for you
but most people are not like you most people they
get meaning out of Life by selecting those things
that appear to be be overall good and just and
uh and and uh working to build them up that's you
know that's how we know that we're doing something
that's that's worthy in life you're I'm gonna ask
you two questions number one if as a conservative
do you have to be religious do you have to believe
in a religion and number two there's another
question hasn't religion played its own his
part in its own time for particularly organized
religion when you look at the corruption endemic
in the church for instance I was raised Catholic
I look at what the Catholic has done particularly
its abuses when it comes to Children the the
rancid cover-ups of success of numerous popes
I'm like no wonder people don't believe it anymore
after what they have done okay well look first of
all I'm not I I'm I'm not a Catholic I'm I'm an
orthodox Jew and I I don't want to be pulled into
um you know into trying to to uh to defend a
particular uh religious framework I mean I I
certainly there are you know my my good friend
Rod drier was uh was uh was a Catholic and he
was one of the uh reporters who led the uh the the
the the um uh in in the 2000s the investigations
the journalistic investigations into uh into
the things you're describing in the church and
he himself decided uh to convert to Orthodox
Christianity uh because of his because of his
experiences with the Catholic church now look my
a religious worldview is one that begins by saying
um human beings are crummy Christians say human
beings are Fallen we we just don't speak that
way but we we do think that human beings are
are um are extremely fallible and and uh tend
towards all sorts of evil things and um every
Human Institution and every human political
Theory uh whether you know whether it's liberal
or conservative Christian or Jewish or or or
any other imperialist or nationalist every human
ideology is going to have examples of people who
are bad people and policies that are bad policies
and evil things that are done in its name okay you
know people people say to me isn't the church
evil and uh you know certainly the church has
done evils but you you know the to the evils of
the church actually uh compete with the evils
of atheists like Stalin and Hitler and Mao well
okay you we can argue about this but I think you
know where we started was uh was what brings what
brings meaning to the life of the individual uh
an individual sitting on the sideline saying
why should I fight um I I'm not saying that
you should fight for every single inherited
tradition I'm saying that you yourself will
get take up meaning and self-esteem and re and
and self-worth when you join a community that you
think is on the whole uh something that improves
human life that on the whole hands down things
that make things uh better so look I I always tell
people if you grew up in a Christian family then
you should start with Christianity because that's
your inheritance but somebody who finds the road
blocked and uh uh should they should they pursue
uh Judaism or some other inheritance it's possible
my my my my wife uh grew up in a Christian family
and she she uh in adults would became a convert
to Judaism and I know people who went the opposite
direction as well and so look there's every single
tradition that you point to you can find uh things
things that are uh wrong and even even evil with
it every single one but if you as a person want
to be able to do something other than sitting on
the sidelines while history makes the decisions
for you then you have to take aside you have to
pick the one that you think is the best and
throw yourself into repairing and making that
as best as it can be and what do you think is
going to happen you're if we don't pick a side
uh well the the the um uh look I I I think
the writing is already on the wall I mean uh
look we can we can make light of uh of woke
as an online phenomenon uh but I don't I don't
think it's simply an online phenomenon I woke
is woke is a descendant of uh of Marxism and it
um uh it it it chapter seven of my book I I I
I I go into exactly why but it's it's a it is
a framework that uh sees sees human societies as
consisting of contending groups uh and defines
whoever is strongest which by the way I I think
that's reasonable that part but uh but marxists
go further and they say that whoever is the the
leading group the dominant group is uh inevitably
oppressing and exploiting the weaker groups and
instead of seeking some kind of accommodation and
uh that will allow the different groups to to get
what they need and to live in peace uh Marx calls
for the the exploited groups to overthrow and
Destroy uh the the ruling class the dominant class
now this wokism is a is is a is a version of this
Theory it it is both explicitly and implicitly a
revolutionary movement whose purpose is to destroy
whatever it is that the the dominant classes have
inherited the dominant in classes in in Britain
and most other Western countries today are liberal
and what wokeism seeks to destroy be above and
beyond anything else is the dominant liberalism
now what do you what do you get if uh if if uh
you you destroy the dominant liberalism and you
don't have some some kind of uh sophisticated
and uh healthful conservatism to to replace
it what what you get is an ongoing Revolution
which will will look like a communist country
if you want if you if you want if you want
to live in the old Soviet Union that's the
direction that we're going um what evidence do you
have for this your what have you seen that that
is saying to you that we're moving towards
you the USSR or like in my case Venezuela
what's the evidence look if if if you um if you
read history especially right now we're talking
about the history of ideas right we're talking
we're talking about what is the dominant idea
in a place like like the Soviet Union and and
how does that end up working out and the the
the claim that the marxists always made um the
their their claim was Injustice is the result
of the evil that is done in the name of uh uh of
the bourgeoisie that's what we call liberalism
today the liberal classes they they claim to bring
freedom and equality but in fact what they bring
is oppression okay that that was Marx's argument
and it's now been tried as as a political system
in you know in dozens of countries um and uh
including including in Venezuela and in in uh
in in Russia and China there hasn't been a single
instance in which the revolution that Marx calls
for that some version of it has been brought into
being that that doesn't uproot and Destroy both
the things that are inherited and cherished that
are conservative like religion and family uh and
nation and the things that are inherited that are
liberal the the the Liberties and the freedoms
both what's good about conservatism and what's
good about liberalism is is annihilated by Marxism
so what we're looking at the people who are
who who actually Advocate this uh uh this world
view they say well look it's not it's not the old
Marxism because we've we've uh replaced the uh the
revolution of economic classes with a revolution
of uh of uh uh uh gen identity groups a revolution
of of gender groups and racial groups and and and
others sexual orientation and so on and that claim
has actually I mean it it it's interesting it's
true that's the reason we call this neo-marxism
instead of Marxism is is because of the fact
that there is a shift when the revolution is
not strictly an economic Revolution but I guess
guess what guess what the wok neon Marxism by
moving away from the economic revolution of the
old Marxism they've given this great gift to the
woke which is that the woke can take over a
capitalist uh companies can take over um uh
highly profitable companies highly profitable and
uh and prestigious universities in other words the
woke can simply become the new ruling structure
in place of liberalism but the idea of oppressing
and destroying anyone who disagrees remains from
the old Marxism so it's an improved Marxism in in
the sense that it looks like it's more effective
but in the sense that you know that anyone who's
who's lived under such a regime would want to
repeat the experiment I I doubt that very much
hey Francis do you like locals I live in London
Mike so obviously not the only pleasure I get
from the locals is when we show an intimate moment
as we watch a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our community on
locals you mean the one where you get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes content when you thank you space
when you get to ask incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson we're at Weinstein Bill Burr
Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather Hein and others
your questions not just that you can get supporter
only benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and even
a regular meal with me and Francis you also get
phenomenal behind-the-scenes footage of our trip
to America where we met a whole host of incredible
guests and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly giveaways for
locals only the first one will be signed copies
of Andrew Dawes new book plus you get access to
an incredible community of like-minded people who
share means have fun conversations and most
importantly you get to make new friends you
can support us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us more for the
higher tier benefits go to trigonometry.locals.com
go to trigonometry.locals.com and support the show
well this is why Francis and I both opposed
workers before we understood any of these
terms because we were just two idiot Comedians and
suddenly we started talking to people like you who
could explain things but instinctively it's very
clear that this is a highly illiberal ideology
that wants to shut things down prevent people
from expressing their views prevent people from
opposing publicly what they say because if you
oppose it you must be you can't just be counted
with argument you have to be destroyed you're a
bad person TM right so totally with you on that
you're on but one thing coming back to our earlier
conversation about what what you have to offer the
world I would say to you that your slogan has got
to be meaning and fulfillment because as someone
who became a father for the first time seven
months ago now I am starting to realize very
quickly that as something Francis actually always
said which is you know the Fulfillment that you
experience in your life depends primarily on the
people around you your family your friends you
know are they well are they unwell you connected
with them are you disconnected from them and these
are all the things that any form of Marxism will
instinctively attempt to destroy but it's because
like religion these are things that tie you in
uh and that that I think is something that is
definitely people that you should run with which
is you're offering people meaning and happiness
and fulfillment in the world in which people take
a crap ton of antidepressants and all the rest of
it but I want to come back to something that you
mentioned which has become a very dirty word uh in
in our politics in the UK in America and elsewhere
which is nationalism the idea of the nation itself
is a Highly Questionable construct I would put
it to you and anyone who seeks to bring Shrine
or protect it is automatically racist xenophobic
hates people with different skin colors Etc uh is
is that first of all do you think that's accurate
that that is how we know how we see that term but
also how do you can you detoxify it do you need
a new word do you need a new vision you know talk
to us about nationalism and why it's become such a
dirty word look I in general I like the old words
because because you are conservative it makes
sense no I but but but for a reason I think I I
think that when previous generations uh worked and
developed uh developed a word it's usually part of
a a scheme it's usually part of a group of ideas
rather than an individual word and in in general
um these inherited schemes of ideas they're
what allow us to find uh not only meaning but
but even truth in reality that doesn't mean that
the inherited schemes don't sometimes need to be
repaired but I I when when I hear an old word
um I before I reject it I would like to know
what was good about that word what was true about
it you know maybe in the end I'll decide that I
don't like it but I want to know why did it work
so well and the uh the idea of the nation and
the independent nation with the the the term
nationalism is I I think that you're right that
there you know are many uh liberal but especially
Marxist circles in which the word nationalism is
uh is a you know some kind of terrible word and
the the reason for it is pretty straightforward
um that uh the the idea of nationalism is
uh the idea that the world is governed best
when there are many different independent
nations that can each one can chart its
own course according to its own traditions and
its own ideas now this this idea enters enters
into uh the history of the world uh in in the
time of the Bible it's a very very old idea
um the the um the Bible when I'm talking about
the Bible as a as a political document I'm not you
don't have to you know believe in one religion or
another to understand what I'm saying the the the
Bible is politically it's an anti-imperial
anti-imperial document it's filled with
um with Empires whose goal is to conquer the
entire world so that's the Assyrian Empire
the Babylonian Empire the Egyptians the Persians
the the uh the the the Romans later all of these
Empires are they're very different from one
another but they have one thing or at least
one thing in common which is that each one of
them has a God or gods that orders the king to
conquer the four corners of the Earth in order
to bring peace and prosperity to Mankind and
that's not that's not a stupid dream the idea of
Conquering the whole world because the the claim
is that when the world is divided then there are
ceaseless Wars and conquests and these these these
wars destroy the economy they they bring disease
and death and so the goal of the imperialist is to
is always to eliminate uh competition and Warfare
and to bring peace and prosperity the Bible Rebels
against this worldview and says look no that's
that's not the right way the right way is that
each Nation should have a border that it doesn't
cross each Nation should be independent it should
find its own way to God it should have a a king
as it says in Deuteronomy a king that comes from
its own people uh prophets that come from its own
people in other words it's an it's an argument for
uh for the freedom of um large groups of people if
the freedom of society is to say we don't want to
go the way a different Society is going we want
to go our way and to try to make that work and
uh so a nationalist is somebody who'll say look um
let's try to have this tolerance for other nations
that do things differently from us and in the end
it may turn out that their way is in some ways
better than ours and then we'll be able to learn
from them and vice versa okay so when when the
the the the word nationalist is is used and it's
sort of uh normative sense in the last couple of
centuries it was it was usually a progressive
term it was a a a a term that said instead of
somebody sitting in you know in in Beijing or
in in Washington and deciding how the the entire
planet should be operated why don't we allow
uh different different ways of life different
uh ways of thinking to flourish and we'll find
out in the long term which one which one is best
[Music] I'm sure that is the trajectory of How
It's been used before but that's not what the
word nationalism means if you read it in a
newspaper today a nationalist is someone who
hates immigrants who doesn't want who wants to
close the borders uh who is uh quite likely to
be some kind of ideological descendant either of
Adolf Hitler who was a German nationalist or uh
people might look around and go well Vladimir
Putin he's reincarnated a Russian nationalism
which is causing the war in Ukraine that's
what people think about quite often now when
they talk about nationalism and so when you say
National conservatism it's like it's it's both
those bad words in one combination Europe okay
well uh guilty for having combined the words
um and uh and and uh if if the if the
words scare people well you know that's
not so bad that means we can have a good
a good a good discussion about it the the
um uh look at your you you're you're sort of right
about Hitler and you're sort of wrong about Putin
or I don't know if if you're asking on behalf
of someone else but someone who says that Putin
is a nationalist uh is simply ignorant no I agree
he's an imperialist primarily he is but but he is
building up He is building a Russian nationalism
in terms of we Russians we're Superior to others
Etc that is happening if look every every Empire
is is run by you know one one nation or one or two
Nations but just to be just to be clear about
this in Putin's own speech now I'm talking
about the way he understands himself Putin Putin
sees Russia explains Russia as a multinational
a multinational Federation you know something
like the austro-hungarian Empire he doesn't he
that's his that's the way that he present for
him he the the the the Nationalist Nazis are
the ukrainians because they stand up in the way
of the multinational Empire that he's trying to
build okay so so let's put fujin aside Hitler
is more interesting because uh because Hitler
does in fact use the word word nationalism and
so for for uh me to uh uh to try to revive the
earlier use of the word which which is what I'm
doing I do really have to deal with the fact that
you know Hitler's mind conf which I you know I
don't I don't recommend the book but if you if
you read it then you'll see that uh that the way
that Hitler uh appropriates the word nationalism
he takes it away from you know from the from from
the Nationalist Visionaries uh of the 19th century
who were you know uh who spoke the way I speak
and and he says well actually I have a new new
definition of the word nationalism and uh and and
you'll see that it's the opposite he uses the word
to mean to mean the opposite he explicitly treats
the idea of independent nation and he rejects them
he rejects the idea of a world of independent
nations he explicitly says that there needs to
be a biological competition among races and that
that competition has to end with Germany being the
Mistress of the globe and Lord of the earth okay
so so that by the traditional definition Hitler is
a biological imperialist there is no nationalism
in Hitler despite the fact that he used that word
now we have to decide since he's taken he's taken
what I think was it was basically a good sound
word and he's he's corrupted it and turned it into
its opposite so what should I do so some people
say okay let's just drop the word nationalism
let's say let's call it patriotism okay so that's
that's for example Orwell or we'll say okay
let's give the word nationalism to Hitler and
we'll just call ourselves Patriots the the pro the
problem uh that that I have with this other than
the fact that I don't like the fact that that a
tradition that I inherited from my father and from
my ancestors that that tradition needs to be given
up because of uh because among other things Hitler
not only uh killed my people and yours uh but
uh but uh and and and destroyed Europe but also
in addition we have to give up our traditional
terms because he he destroyed those two so in
part I just don't I don't like that but I also
have you know as a as a scholar of the subject
I I have a little bit of a problem which is that
sometimes when you give up words you cease to be
able to express the idea properly and patriotism
is uh it's it's very close to nationalism but
patriotism is refers uh it in every usage that I'm
familiar with it refers to loving your own country
I'm I'm a patriot of uh of England or of the UK
I'm a patriot of of Israel or of America or of
India um that's a perfectly good usage of the
word but patriotism is not a description never
has been used as a description for a proposal
for a the best for for a better world order
nationalism is a description it's a proposal for
how to better run the world it doesn't just say I
love my country nationalism means I I I I love my
country but I also make space for my neighbors to
love their country that's the reason that a border
between us is is a useful thing because good good
borders make good neighbors so nationalism is uh
I I in 2018 I published a book called The Virtue
of nationalism nationalism is a is a virtue to
the extent that what it means is that we develop
the type of Personality that is capable of on the
one hand seeking out what's what's good and worthy
in our own in our own Nation but on the other
recognizing the the uh the boundaries of what we
understand and allowing that other people should
have that same freedom to to to experiment and try
to create something good that's different in their
Nation now I if you give up the word nationalism
the problem is there is no substitute for that
word you you simply erase the political Theory
I had just described because there's no there is
no other word for it isn't part of the problem as
well with nationalism in Europe is that this idea
that our way of life is better which then leads to
the Arrogant assumption that you can then impose
your way of life and your belief system on other
countries as in bringing democracy to Iraq Etc
and it doesn't work because people are fundamental
these people are fundamentally different their
culture is different yes I I I I agree with you
but I think that uh but I I think that what
you're describing is a liberal imperialism it
is it is it is uh look let me let me just back
up for one second um conservatism is is unlike
conservatism which is a world view that's based
on on different traditions in different places
and different times conservatism isn't it's not
a universal theory like liberalism or Marxism
liberalism and Marxism are both of them are
theories that claim that they have the answer
for how we should be governed in every time
in every place in history that's what makes
them them both in different ways revolutionary uh
revolutionary ideologies or political theories a
liberal who says that and and this has been a
great many uh uh liberals have have made this
argument that that Locke or uh Rousseau or Spinoza
or Kant or their descendants that they discovered
the universal answer to how all human beings must
live the only the one legitimate way to live and
Rousseau says explicitly the the others say it
implicitly Rousseau says explicitly there is
only one legitimate Constitution which is which is
The Enlightenment liberal Constitution any other
Constitution Rousseau says that if it varies in
the slightest then it's illegitimate and has to be
overthrown now when we're talking about these the
this this uh reprehensible theory that uh that uh
uh people sitting in Washington or or you know
in London or in Brussels that their political
worldview is so correct that it justifies going
to Iraq or Afghanistan or any other corner of the
world and imposing that worldview on a different
country that is precisely liberal imperialism and
it's it is inherent in Enlightenment liberalism
because of the claim that that the liberal theory
is universal that it's the only correct theory for
all times and places you reminded me uh someone
who grew up in the Soviet Union you mentioned
that Marxism has this uh you know feeling that
it can explain everything everywhere there was
a there was an old Soviet joke about a guy who
invents a public shaving machine uh and he goes
to the whatever commissary that's supposed to
evaluate this potential new invention and he
explains the model he says well what happens
is you stick your face in it and these blades come
out and they cut off your stubble and everything
is fine and the guy looks at him goes yeah but
everyone's got a different face shape and you
know body type and everything you know different
stubble length uh you know people might put their
face in and it's not the right shape and when he
says well don't worry it's only the first time
repeat for using repeatedly using it is going to
fix that problem isn't it but you mentioned the
um that is that is the way these people think
that they've got the one solution that's fit
one size fits all it always works and if if it
doesn't work it's because you are at fault as
opposed to the machine that they came up with
that that's a that's exactly that's explicitly
exactly what what we're told is is you spent 20
years trying to to bring liberal liberalism to
Afghanistan uh Why didn't it work well look there
there are also sorts of problems in the execution
there's always problems in the execution there's
never ever a flaw in the idea right uh but what
I was really piqued my curiosity uh in what you
were saying is you mentioned that conservatism
doesn't have that view right and can you explain
a little bit more about that difference yes
um if you'll allow me again to just just
touch on on on the Bible there's this
um remarkable um uh issue in that I think you
you see it almost immediately when when you
start studying the Hebrew Bible is that uh Moses
is supposed to be talking to God creator of Heaven
and Earth and he gets a law from you know the
law from God the Ten Commandments and so on and
and this law is supposed to be something that's
going to improve um conditions For All Mankind
and there's all sorts of texts that say so now the
question is so if that's if this is a universal
um thought you know these Ten Commandments
then then why does God give Moses borders
and say you're not allowed to cross
them you're not allowed to take one
inch of your neighbor's land uh because I've
given their land to to these other nations
and so there there is this tension from the very
beginning in the uh uh in the Jewish and Christian
tradition which is uh you know played out also
in in uh in England the common law tradition and
in the UK and that tension is between the
thought that we actually think that we've
discovered something that would be that could be
good for many other peoples but on the other hand
that doesn't give us the right to go out and
conquer them and impose these ideas by force
so this is this is kind of this is the the
original source of uh of the anglo-american
conservative tradition uh which which wants to
say on the one hand there is something that is
that is uniquely good uh about Britain there
is something that's uniquely good about the
the uh the British or the American tradition
but the to take the additional step which
says the fact that we have something uniquely
good gives us a right to impose it on others
that that that's where it's supposed to stop so
if you take let's say um John Ford excusing Praise
of the laws of of England which you if you you
haven't read it I I recommend it to especially
to Brits but to everybody it's a short book it's
it's believe it or not it's from the 1400s and
you just open it it's like it's it's beautifully
written like it was written you know yesterday and
uh and uh Fortescue says look the common law the
laws of England they just are the best laws that
anybody's ever had but then he starts he turns to
France and Germany and he addresses the question
of you know should the French and the Germans
simply adopt the English Constitution he says
no because the the laws of France and Germany
may be better suited for their conditions for
their their their economic conditions their
religious conditions the the character of
the people he he leaves open the possibility
that over time things could be changed and
improved in France or Germany but he doesn't he he
disallows the the the the step that goes because
we have the freest country and we have the best
laws therefore they should be adopted by others
jorm do you think part of the problem with your
message is to put it bluntly conservatism and
nationalism aren't sexy well but they're not like
no one puts Edmund Burke on a t-shirt I'm sorry
I've seen loads of Che Guevara I've never seen
Edmund Burke you know look isn't that isn't that
the real challenge here yeah look I don't know me
maybe if I can maybe if I convince you know sexy
guys like yourselves you're barking up the wrong
tree my friend then we'll have some kind of Hope
of winning you know because you're right I'm just
yeah like this Poor's love right writes books I
I succeeded in conning my wife into thinking
that it was worth throwing in with me um but
you know what can I tell you um let's um let's
make the following the the following agreement
um I may not know how to make something sexy uh
but it doesn't it doesn't mean necessarily that
it's not going to appeal to a young generation
which is facing here's the alternative they're
facing the alternative they're facing is to
just let the woke neo-marxists win not just
to win at the level of government but also to win
in your personal life and what I'm saying is that
there there has to be an alternative and think
about it for a second that alternative is not
going to be liberalism okay it's not going to
be liberalism because liberalism is what brought
woke neo-marxism it's the every single institution
that the woke Neo marxists are running now was a
liberal institution 15 years ago so if liberalism
had the antibodies if it was enough to say let's
just be free if that was strong enough to be able
to defeat woke Neo Marxism we wouldn't be where
we are today so sexy or not people have to ask the
following question I think they have to if I want
to have as you say meaning fulfillment purpose
a decent life for me my family my friends my
children my grandchildren if I want that so I have
to I have no choice I have to start thinking about
what did I inherit which gave me the possibility
of a decent life and what can I do to make sure
that it's handed down today that is in a sense
a a it's a counter-revolutionary thought to say
to say liberalism wasn't good enough it brought
Marxism what can we do now let's let let's look
through the closet of the things that we have
in our inheritance and see what could actually
what used to work what could work for us look
I I don't know when I was 18 I thought that was
pretty exciting well there you go but you're um
you you make an interesting point and I I want
to ask you something about liberalism because this
is a question I've been wrestling with uh first of
all I'd love for you to explain why you believe
that liberalism has been as susceptible as it
has been to this illiberal ideology and also once
once you've kind of in fact why don't you answer
that and I'll ask you the question well look the
the the question here is is really about what are
human beings really like okay because because
liberals assume and I again I'm talking about
the the the thing that's handed down from from uh
from from uh lock and spinos and Hobbs and content
and all the way down to today where you know
liberalism and Marxism are the two things that
are basically taught in the universities and and
so the the basic idea what is a human being like
that liberals start with and end with is human
beings are fundamentally free creatures that are
rational they can make their own decisions they'll
get to the truth by arguing with one another and
and and and they don't need to take on any
obligations except the ones that make sense
to them that's it that's the that's the liberal
idea okay so there's a lot that's Noble there
there's a lot that's obviously attractive there
especially especially by the way to teenagers
who I've had no seriously at this point of race
you know what I'm my wife and I are raising our
eighth and Ninth teenagers and so we know I know
something about teenagers and teenagers they get
you know they they get to a certain stage and the
hormones are running wild and they're built to
to start questioning things which is good that's
what allows them to become strong and independent
the problem is that that afterwards after they do
their you know their their their Rebellion thing
and they're reconsidering thing they're supposed
to land somewhere and start building something if
you have a a liberal society in which the schools
and the government that everybody the churches
everybody's constantly teaching the only thing
you need is to be free and to think for yourself
if that's all you're teaching then the things
that are necessary to inherit and transmit to
live a life of inheriting and fixing things and
restoring them and transmitting them in better
shape every single thing that you need to do that
is not included in the kit that's the problem is
that you tell two generations of liberals of
this by the way this is mostly the way I grew
up also that you tell two generations of of kids
at home and in school and you keep telling them
just think for yourself and guess what you the
the the the the the the implicit premise is that
they're all going to come out liberals but the
truth is they don't come out liberals because
they do think for themselves and a lot of them
come out Marxist and some of them even come come
out like racialists and fascists and and today
looking at two generations of this experiment but
we we eliminated God we we eliminated scripture
we we eliminated tradition you don't have to be
like your parents you don't have to be like your
nation we got rid of all these obligations so
does it last no it doesn't last it does it can't
sustain itself because because since nothing is
being inherited and transmitted basically what
you're telling kids they reach 18 and you send
them to college you say all right you're you're
just going to hang out with 18 year olds for the
next five years four years and and and there's
there's going to be no inheritance you make it
up figure it out for yourselves there are no
Role Models there is no Community there's no
church the professors that come give a
lecture once in a while but there's no
inheritance and so they think for themselves
and guess what they come out with Marxism
yarm and this is a question that uh I again have
being a recent father that's made me think about
a lot because I can feel my views on things change
as I watch my son grow because I am someone who's
very liberal when it comes to drugs for example
uh and I believe in decriminalizing many drugs
however when I think do I want my son to be able
to buy heroin at the pharmacy when he turns 16 or
18 or whatever probably not right how much do
you think that some of these movements are the
product of the declining birth rate in Western
societies where people delay defer and sometimes
abstain from having children entirely and that
is something that clearly has an impact on how
you view the world yeah no that's that's exact
that's exactly exactly right that that if you
come and visit you know my Orthodox Jewish
Community where there are you know there's
there's 15 synagogues in the neighborhood and uh
and and people are raising large families and they
get married young okay and they have many children
so a society like that is a society in which you
know not every single individual but in general
what happens is that that you grow up with uh
with uh many families around you you you see early
marriage and uh and and bringing children into the
world you're not scared of it because you know it
well you see how it's done by the way keeping them
keeping a marriage together is one of the hardest
things a human being can do in life it's a skill
you can't just marry somebody having never seen
it done and expect expect that you know how to
do it just like just like child child rearing
and and and running a congregation and running
a nation staying married is a skill that needs
to be learned and so young people who grow up
around mothers and fathers that stayed married
despite the incredible difficulties and hardship
of doing it but they stayed married for 40 or 50
years those people learn how to do it and young
people grow up around uh children being raised
and rebellious teenagers who then come back to the
fold and and continue to work to to to hand on the
Traditions these are all skills that you learn by
being part of that kind of community and if you're
not part of that kind of community you can think
all sorts of crazy things about about what you can
do about what what is actually possible one of the
things that is not possible is to uh is to wait
until you're 35. marry somebody have a child for
the first time at the age of 35 when you're you're
you yourself do not have families around you that
are models for how to do it and think that you're
going to be able to raise your children to to to
to be happy well adjust just in strong people it
it it's factually not true just come visit come
look I'm making a it's an empirical challenge just
go look at conservative societies conservative
communities and how they work and and and you'll
you'll start to think well maybe I just was raised
to think the wrong things oh I agree with you and
it's something we think about a lot both of us
um as we go through our own journey of kind of
unwinding some of the societal programming and and
all the rest of it the last question in this line
of thinking that I wanted to ask you around is
how much of an inherent conflict does there have
to be between liberalism and conservatism because
from my perspective there are things in my life
that I'm definitely conservative minded about
there are definitely things in my life that are
I'm liberally minded about now that could be you
know a sign of my mental ill health but it could
also be a sign of the fact that actually there
are many portions of these two World Views that
are perfectly combinable together I think there's
probably nothing within a healthy version of
conservatism that for example says well we
mustn't have freedom of speech it might say well
you have your freedom to express these views we
don't agree with them we don't like them we don't
believe in them but you are allowed to express
them you're not going to be punished or put in
prison for saying that but we as a society don't
necessarily agree with that right right um it may
have a liberalism around other things does there
is there an inherent conflict between the two
visions and if so where is it look there there
are indeed many things on which um uh anti-marxist
liberals and uh conservatives can agree and uh and
and should agree today and and and in fact we need
to to be working together and developing uh the
kinds of friendships and alliances that that will
uh will allow us to to uh to do things like like
maintaining Free Speech Traditions but there there
is a fundamental disagreement between uh between
um mainstream liberals and mainstream
conservatives about what exactly it is we're
defending even on the issue of free speech because
um most of my liberal friends are under the uh the
the mistaken impression that that the freedom to
speak is in some way natural that it is you know
that you just do it you know everybody does it you
know just leave people alone government should get
out of the way and it'll be fine everybody you'll
have the right to free speech this is absolutely
false but again this is the kind of thing try
try raising a family of nine children any number
of children and you will immediately see that
there is no natural free speech that the that the
the way that freedom of speech is inculcated is
through an incredibly painful process of getting
people getting young people sitting around a
dinner table sitting around the living room
to artificially restrain themselves from stepping
look what's the natural thing the natural thing is
for the kid to say shut up I don't like that you
you you can't say that and then to charge over and
start hitting them that's the natural thing all
kids are natural that's that's the nature of what
happens when people speak freely naturally the the
the custom of no you're going to wait your turn
you're going to be quiet until your sister is done
talking when she's now it's your turn now how you
speak it is incredibly difficult to inculcate and
it can only be implicated through a custom through
a tradition of teaching children how to do that
and then they grow up and then they continue doing
it as adults because they learned as children so
even on Free Speech we have a disagreement about
whether it's natural or whether it's a tradition
conservatives say it's a learned tradition that
has to be inculcated and that allows conservatives
also to disagree with liberals on on the following
kind of thing if you think that if you're a
liberal and you think that freedom is basically
the the Supreme value individual liberty then
you find it difficult to balance individual
liberties with other other necessary Goods which
conservatives uh believe in so for for for example
uh a conservative will tend to say having an
iPhone with having having hardcore pornography
available on everybody's iPhone every 12 year old
is gonna in his pocket is going to have hardcore
pornography because that's freedom of speech a
conservative will say no that is not our tradition
of freedom of speech there is an anglo-tradition
of freedom of speech it goes back 500 years it's
principally related to political speech we can
extend it to all sorts of other things but that
doesn't mean that we have to uh you know Go the
whole way and say anything that anybody feels like
taking a photograph of has to be circulated by any
medium whatsoever to our children and liberals and
conservatives will disagree about that it's
a very good point joram um the one aspect of
this conversation that I think we're missing is
a whole economic aspect of it in which you look
at these kids who come out and they're woke or
you know Marxist whatever you want to call it
and look we can criticize and we can say what
they believe is wrong and and I agree with that
but it's very difficult to ask young people to
be conservative when the gap between rich and
poor is growing ever wider when it's becoming
more and more difficult to own property and a
lot of people will look at themselves will look
at society that they are emerging into and going
well why do you want me to conserve all of
this when you don't allow me access to it
yeah I I think you're actually going
to uh to like my book on on this score
um the the conservative does not does not think
that the responsibility of government is only to
defend individual freedoms no matter what their
consequences are so um uh my my teacher Irvin
Crystal uh wrote a book called reflections of a
neoconservative just you should flag that the word
neoconservative was used in a completely different
way 30 years ago from the way it's used now and
um uh he wrote a book called two cheers for
capitalism and um and his on his understanding was
that the purpose the first purpose of government
is is to maintain the nation maintaining the
nation means that the different groups in the
nation have to be loyal to one another they have
to maintain a certain degree of uh Allegiance
and trust with one another and the in any kind
of theoretical philosophical principle which you
know like like uh like the free market which is
uh which is healthy and good I mean we're going
all the way back to Fortescue we're talking about
again in the 1400s says he foreske says you know
why why is England the freest freest uh Nation on
Earth it's because because we're careful because
we're careful with property because the English
king is not allowed to um to enter the home of uh
the poorest um farmer without the permission of of
the farmer all right so that there is property as
as an important part of this Anglo tradition but
if you get to the point where uh where the the
uh the the uh accumulation of wealth in a small
number of hands um is uh is beginning to cause
the rupture of the society well so that's Disraeli
right I mean we're we're discussing what what is
one nation conservatism One Nation conservatism is
the the uh the introduction of uh minimum social
safety net by the conservative uh the conservative
party and the reason that they introduced it was
was because um the the uh they they looked at
industrialization they looked at the vast wealth
that industrialization was creating they looked at
the dislocation of the traditional the traditional
um uh family and social structures which had
um uh which which had protected people and they
said look we we're going to have a revolution and
and and justifiably so because because people know
they've been torn away from from everything that
used to protect them and and now we have to step
in and come up with with a new Arrangement uh that
allows uh the the wealthiest and the poorest and
the working class to be able to live together as
one nation to be able to maintain loyalty to one
another and that is not that is not what happens
when you take the free market as an absolute
and you say this is the final ultimate principle
that makes sense Francis I suppose a question
for us bridge that would be interesting to ask
is you're um you've got your dream I mean it's
2023 we have had a conservative left government
in this country for 13 years right they don't
seem to have delivered any of the things that
you claim are the virtues of conservatism
what's going on what's going on is that um is
is that uh I I mentioned it at the beginning that
post-world War II uh the major political parties
in the UK and in America and across Europe adopted
different forms of liberalism and in in particular
um after 1989 after the fall of the Berlin Wall
um the the uh the the the the conservatism of
uh the uh the Reagan Thatcher uh John Paul II
era was a conservatism that still had elements
of uh nationalism and uh and and religion and
traditional moral morals as as part of the package
you can say not enough you can argue about that
but but it was still part of the package as soon
as Reagan and Thatcher are shoved aside there is
uh the the movement that that was that went by the
name of conservatism became a radical liberal
movement it became a liberal internationalist
movement George H.W bush announced the uh the
the new world order in which for the first time
in a hundred Generations he says a hundred
Generations have struggled to try to reach
the the imposition of a a liberal International
order on the entire planet and we today are going
to do it now that that is not conservative
it's not conservative it's not conservatism
it's more correct to call it neoliberalism but
liberal International order is is uh is I think
the the best most accurate name for it it's the
idea that liberal ideas should be imposed on the
entire Globe under a single a single legal
system them with with the American Army and
some help from the Brits in enforcing it and
that theory uh has dominated the Tory party
for since since Thatcher was pushed off the stage
and uh continues to have a strong influence on the
Tories to this day and so when when I'm talking
about conservatism I'm not telling you that you
should vote for the for for the the conservative
party in the UK no matter what it does I'm telling
you what the tradition of conservatism of
anglo-conservatism was and I look forward to
the the day when the Tories and if not the Tories
then some some other political party uh will adopt
a a a a conservative platform I believe that that
conservative platform in addition to Simply being
uh uh being uh correct philosophically I also
think that uh that we got to see in the 2019
election the potential electorally today of
a of an actual conservative looking platform
to uh to to just to Sweet Britain the fact that
the Tories don't know how to implement what was
in that platform well so they may end up losing
an election or two uh you know in order to learn
do you think that your version of conservative
is essentially incompatible with globalization
incompatible with with multinational Corp uh
cooperation uh conservatives can can you know
certainly believe in uh in uh alliances of mutual
interest in trade where it's where it's mutually
beneficial in in learning from other countries
and exchanging with other I mean all of these
things are compatible with with the world of
independent nations what's not compatible is
um is the idea of erasing the borders uh of of
uh um of a single currency for you know for for
tens or hundreds of Nations it's not compatible
with the world government it's not compatible
with a with a world judicial system that you
know imposes the ideas of of uh of Brussels or
Washington on the whole world but so I would say
yes cooperation and mutual exchange absolutely but
a a a a common government or governance Over
All Nations it's it's just poison just say no
you're I think we're we're running out of time
so uh I've really enjoyed our conversation I
recommend everybody gets the book conservatism
a rediscovery and as always before we ask you
our questions from our local supporters that
only they will get to see uh what is the one
thing that we're not talking about in
your opinion that we really should be
there are many things here's here's one
what is it what does it mean what does it mean
the people that that young people are afraid
to have children they don't want to have children
anymore what is what does that tell you what does
that teach you what should we do about it I think
it tells you everything if you think about it
you're it's been an absolute pressure thank you
so much for coming on the show if people want to
find you online if people want to buy your book
where is the best place to do that well the the
book is on on Amazon or Book Depository or any
any other place that sells books a conservatism
or rediscovery if you want to learn about and
to get involved with or to just to think about
the national conservatism movement uh take a look
at national conservatism.org uh or natcon.org you
can get there National conservatism.org is where
uh the young people who think that it's sexy too
that it's uh sexy to uh to uh preserve your uh
your nation and your inheritance improve it and
pass it on to Future Generations please consider
coming thank you so much and thank you guys for
watching and listening we will see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this one oral
show all of them go out at 7 pm UK time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys is a greater danger to
conservatism the left or the pendulum in political
thoughts swinging so violently back the other way
that it goes straight past conservatism
into genuine far-right ideology [Music]